let's start with this classic system
that i keep referring to in our
thermodynamics videos i have a cylinder
it's got a little piston on the top of
it or it's got a a ceiling that's
movable the gas and we're thinking of
mono
ideal gases in here they're exerting
some pressure onto this onto this
ceiling and the reason why the ceiling
isn't moving all the way up is because
i've placed a bunch of rocks on the top
to offset the force per area of the
actual gas and i start this gas when you
know when it's in equilibrium i can
define its macro states it has some
volume it has some pressure that's being
offset by these rocks and it has some
well-defined temperature
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
place this system here
i'm going to place it on top of a
reservoir and i talked about what a
reservoir was either in the last video a
couple of videos ago you can view it as
an infinitely large
object if you will of a certain
temperature so if i put it next to if i
put our system next to this reservoir
and let's say i start removing pebbles
from our system
we learned a couple of videos ago that
if we did it adiabatically what does
adiabatically mean if we did if we
remove these pebbles in isolation
without any reservoir around
the volume would increase the pressure
would go down and actually the
temperature would decrease as well we
showed that in in a couple of videos ago
so by putting this big reservoir there
that's a lot larger than our actual
canister
this will keep the temperature in our
canister at t1 you can kind of view a
reservoir as
you know
let's say i had a
a a cup of water in a stadium and the
stadium is the air conditioner in the
stadium is at 60 degrees
well no matter what i do to that water
if i could i could put it in the
microwave and warm it up but if i put it
back in that stadium that stadium is
going to keep that water at 60 degrees
and you might say oh won't the
reservoir's temperature decrease if it's
throwing off heat well it would but it's
so much larger that it's its impact
isn't noticeable for example if i put a
cup of boiling water into into a super
large covered domed stadium
the water will get colder to the the
ambient temperature of the stadium the
stadium will get warmer but it'll be so
marginally warmer that you won't even
notice it so you can kind of view that
as a reservoir and theoretically this is
infinitely large so the effect of this
is as we remove these little rocks we're
going to keep the temperature constant
and remember if we're keeping the
temperature constant we're also keeping
the internal energy constant because
we're not changing the kinetic energy of
the particles so let me see what happens
so i keep doing that
and so i get to a point
let me see
where my volume has increased so let me
delete
some of my rocks here
delete some of the rocks
so some of the rocks are gone
and now my overall
volume is going to be larger so let me
move this up a little bit
and then let me color this in black
oh whoops
let me color this in just to give an
idea
so our volume has gotten a bit larger
let me get my pen
correctly okay so our volume has gotten
larger
by roughly this mount we have the same
number of particles they're going to
bump into the ceiling a little less
frequently so my pressure would have
gone down but because i kept this
reservoir here because this reservoir
was here the whole time
during this process
the temperature stayed at t1 and that
was only because of this
only because of this reservoir and i
want to make that clear and also just to
review this is a quasi-static process
because i'm doing it very slowly the
system is in equilibrium the whole time
so let's draw
let's draw what we have so far on our
famous pv diagram
so this is
this is
p axis
that's the v axis
right label them
this is p
this is v
let me call this let me do a good color
this is state a
of the system this is state b of the
system so state a starts at some
pressure and volume
i'll do it like that
that's state a
and it moves to state b and notice i
kept the temperature constant what did
we learn in i think it was one or two
videos ago
well we're at a constant temperature so
we're going to move along an isotherm
which is just a a a rectangular
hyperbola because your when your
temperature is constant your pressure
times your volume is going to equal a
constant number and i went over that
before so we're going to move over
our path is going to look something like
this
and i'll move here
to stage b
i'll move over here to state b and the
whole time this was at a constant
temperature t1
t1
d1 now we've done a bunch of videos now
we said okay how much work was done on
this system
well the work done on the system is the
area under this curve so some positive
work was not done on the system sorry
how much work was done by the system
we're moving in this direction i should
put the direction there
we're moving from left to right the
amount of work done by the system is
pressure times volume we've seen that
multiple times so you take this area
under the curve and you have the work
done by the system from a to b
right so let's call that work from a to
b
work from a to b
now that's fair and and everything but
what i want to think more about is how
much heat was transferred by my
reservoir remember we said if this
reservoir wasn't there the temperature
of my canister would have gone down as i
expanded its volume and as the pressure
went down so how much heat came into it
well let's go back to our basic internal
energy formula change in internal energy
changes internal energy is equal to heat
applied to the system
minus the work done by the system
now what is the change in internal
energy in this scenario
well i was at a constant temperature the
whole time right
and since we're dealing with a very
simple ideal gas all of our internal
energy is due to kinetic energy which
temperature is a measure of so if
temperature didn't change our average
kinetic energy didn't change which means
our kinetic energy didn't change so our
internal energy did not change while we
moved along this isotherm
while we moved along from left to right
along this isotherm so we could say our
internal energy is zero
and that is equal to the heat added to
the system
minus the work done by the system
right so if you just we get the we put
the the work done by the system on the
other side and then switch the sides you
get heat added to the system is equal to
the work done by
the system and that makes sense the
system was doing some work this entire
time so it was giving energy to
to well you know to it was giving
essentially maybe some potential energy
to some of the to these rocks so it was
giving energy away it was giving energy
outside of the system
so what how did it how did it maintain
its internal energy well someone had to
give it some energy and it was given
that energy by this
by this reservoir
so let's say and the way the convention
for doing this is it's to say that it
was given
let me write this down it was given some
energy q1
we just say we just put this downward
arrow so that some energy went into the
system here
fair enough
now
now let's take
this state b and remove the reservoir so
now and completely isolate ourselves so
there's no way that heat can be
transferred to and from our system and
let's keep removing some rocks
so if we keep removing some rocks where
do we get to let me go down here
so let's say we remove a bunch of more
rocks
so let me
erase some even more rocks than we had
in beast maybe i only have one rock left
i only have one rock left and obviously
the floor the the overall volume would
have increased so let me make our piston
go up
like that and i could make our piston is
maybe a lot higher now
and let me just fill in
the rest of our
just so that we don't have some empty
space there
so if i fill that in right there
okay let me fill that in
and then i just use the blue
this is i should be talking about
thermodynamics not drawing but you get
the idea and then i have some more you
know i shouldn't add particles but my
volume is increased a good bit
my my pressure will have gone down
they're going to bump into each into the
walls less and because
i removed i removed the reservoir what's
going to happen to the temperature
i'm going to my temperature is going to
go down this was an adiabatic process so
an adiabatic just means we did it in
isolation there was no exchange of heat
from one system to another so let me
just this arrow continues down here
and i'll say adiabatic adiabatic
now since i'm moving from one
temperature to another this is now at t2
this is now t2 so i will have moved to
another isotherm this is the isotherm
for t1 if i keep my temperature constant
i move along this hyperbola i would have
kept moving along this hyperbola but now
that we didn't keep our temperature
constant we now move like this we move
to another isotherm so let's say i have
another isotherm at t2 it looks
something like this
so let me draw it like that so let's say
i have another
everything actually let me
it should actually move curve up a
little bit so let's say everything at
temperature t2 depending on its pressure
and volume is someplace along this curve
that asymptotes up like that and then
goes to the right like that now i would
have moved down to this isotherm and my
pressure would have got kept going down
and my volume would have kept going down
so this move from b to
c for to state c will look like this
from b to state c
let me do it in another color let me do
it in the orange color of this arrow
so it'll look like this
and now we are at state c
state c now this was
adiabatic
which means there was no exchange of
heat so i don't have to figure out what
how much heat got transferred into the
system now there's something interesting
here we still did do
we still did do some work we can take
the area under this curve and we're
going to leave it to a future video to
think about where that work energy well
where well
the main thing is is what what was
reduced by that work energy and well if
you think about i it's i don't even have
to leave it to a future video our enter
our our internal energy was reduced
right because our temperature went down
so our internal energy went down we'll
talk more about that in a future video
so now that we're at state c and we're
at temperature t2
let's let's put back another sink here
let's put back another sink
but this sink
what it's going to have
is a reservoir
so let me put two things right here
so this sink so i'm going to add
let me erase some of these
blocks
in black
so now i'm going to add blocks back
i'm going to add
little pebbles back into it but i'm
going to do it
as an isothermic process i'm going to do
it with a reservoir here
but this reservoir here it's not going
to be the same reservoir that i put up
there i swapped that one out i got rid
of any reservoir when i went from b to c
and i'm going to swap in a new reservoir
actually let me make it a
let me make it
let me make it blue because it's going
to be
because here what's happening i'm now
adding pebbles in i'm compressing the
gas
the gas if we were if this was an
adiabatic process the gas would want to
heat up so what i'm doing is i need to
put a reservoir to keep it at t2 to keep
it along this isotherm
so i this is t2 remember this reservoir
is kind of a cold reservoir it keeps the
temperature down as opposed to here this
was a hot reservoir kept the temperature
up so you can imagine there's heat being
the heat generated in the system or
internal energy being generated in the
system well no i shouldn't say that
the temperature of the system will want
to go up but it's being released because
it's able to transfer that heat into our
new reservoir so i'll say and that
amount of heat is q2
q2
so i move along this so this this is
right here i'm moving along another
isotherm i'm moving along this isotherm
until i get to
state d we're almost there
this is state d
so state d will be someplace here along
this isotherm right here maybe this is
state d
and once again you can you can make the
argument that we moved along an isotherm
our temperature did not change
from c to d
we know that our our internal energy
went down from b to c because we did
some work but from c to d our
temperature stayed the same it was at
temperature let me write it down it was
at temperature t2
right because we had this reservoir here
it stayed the same if your temperature
stays the same then your internal energy
stays the same at least for the system
we're dealing with because it's a very
simple gas it's actually the system
you'll deal with most of the time in an
intro thermodynamics course so given our
internal energy didn't change we can
apply the same argument that the
the heat
the heat added to the system is equal to
the work done by the system right same
math as we did up here
now in this case the work wasn't done by
the system the work was done to the
system we compressed this piston the
other the force times distance went the
other way so given that work was done to
the system the heat added to the system
was negative right we're just applying
the same thing heat if our if our
internal energy is zero the heat added
to the system is equal to the work done
by the system the work done by the
system is negative work was done to it
so the heat
added to the system would be negative or
another way to think about it is that
the system gave away heat
we'll say put that with q2
q2 and where did it give that heat it
gave it to this reservoir that we put
here this kind of cold reservoir you can
almost view it as a well just it it's
accepting the heat okay we're almost
there now let's say we remove this
reservoir from under our system again so
it's it's completely isolated from
everything else at least in terms of
heat and what we do is
we start adding so state d it still
wasn't you know we still had a few less
pebbles
but we start adding more pebbles again
we start adding more pebbles to get it
to state a
so let me change to my pebble color so
we start adding more pebbles again to
get it back
to
state a
so that's this process right here
that's this process and let me do a
different color
this is let's say this this is green
so as we add pebbles that's this
movement right here this we're moving
from one isotherm up to another isotherm
at a higher temperature and remember
this whole time we went in this
clockwise direction
so a couple of interesting things are
going on here
because we're assuming an ideal scenario
nothing was lost to friction this piston
just you know moves up and down no heat
loss due to that what we can say is is
that we we've achieved we have we are
back at our original internal energy in
fact this is one of the properties of a
state variable is that if we're at the
same point on the pv diagram the same
exact point we have the same state
variable so now we have the same
pressure volume temperature and internal
energy is what we started with so what
we've done here is completed a cycle in
this particular cycle it's an important
one it's called carnocycle
it's named after a french engineer who's
trying to just optimize engines in the
early 1800s so it's a carnot cycle
carnot cycle and we're going to study
this a lot in the next few videos to
really make sure we understand entropy
correctly because in a lot of chemistry
classes they'll throw entropy at you oh
it's measure of disorder but you really
don't know what it what they're talking
about or how can you quantify it or
measure in any way and we really need to
deal with the carnot cycle
in order to understand where the first
concepts of entropy really came from and
then related to kind of more modern
notions of it now something that com a
system
that completes a carnot cycle is called
a carnot engine so our little piston
here that's moving up and down we can
consider this a carnot engine you might
say oh you saw this doesn't seem like a
great engine i have to move pebbles and
all of that and you're right it's not
you wouldn't actually implement an
engine this way but it's a useful engine
or it's a useful theoretical construct
in order for understanding
how heat is transferred in an engine i
mean if you think about what's happening
here is this first heat sink transferred
some heat to the system
and then the system transferred a
smaller amount of heat back to the
ambient uh back to the other
back to the other reservoir right so
this in this this system was
transferring heat from one reservoir to
another reservoir from a hotter
reservoir to a colder reservoir and in
the process it was also doing some work
and what was the work that it did
well it's the area under this curve we
or the area inside of this cycle so this
is the work done
right this is the work done by our
carnot engine and if the way you think
about it is it's the area when you're
going in the rightward direction with
increasing volume it's the area under
the curve is the work done by the system
and then when you move in the leftward
direction with decreasing volume you
subtract out the work done to the system
and then you're left with just the area
in the curve so we could write this
carnot engine like this
we could write it like this it's taking
it's starting
so you have a reservoir
at t1
and then you have your engine right here
and then it's
connected eventually so it takes it
takes q1 in from this reservoir
it does some work right the work is
represented by the amount of
the work right here is is the area
inside of our cycle
and then it transfers q2 or essentially
the remainder from q1 into our cold
reservoir so t2 so transfers q2 there so
the work we did is really the difference
between q1 and q2
right you say hey if i have more heat
coming in that i'm letting out where did
the rest of that heat go it went to work
literally so q1 minus q2
is equal to the amount of work we did
and actually this is a good time to
emphasize again that heat and work are
not a state variable a state variable
has to be the exact same value when we
complete a cycle now we see here that we
completed a cycle and we had a net
amount of work done or a net amount of
heat added to the system so we could
just keep going around the cycle and
keep having heat added to the system so
there is no inherent heat state variable
right here you can't say what the value
of heat is at this point in time all you
could say is what the amount of heat was
added or taken away from the system or
you can only say the amount of work that
was done to or done by the system anyway
i want to leave you
there right now we're going to study
this a lot more but the real important
thing is and if if you ever want to get
confused in a thermodynamics class i
encourage you to even you know go off on
your own and do this yourself kind of
you can almost you know take a pencil
and paper and and kind of redo this
video that i just did because essential
that you understand the carnot engine
understand this adiabatic process
understand what isotherms are because if
you understand that then a lot of what
we're about to do in the next few videos
regards to entropy will be a little bit
more intuitive and and not too confusing